tipping 20% at a sitdown restaurant is
still the standard um according to most
etiquette experts in the US after
holding stad for years though tipping at
full service restaurants fell to 19.4%
in the second quarter of 2023 according
to online restaurant platform toast most
recent restaurant Trends report notching
the lowest average since the start of
the co 19 pandemic so that's the
headline is that that the Tipping is is
falling people are tipping less tip
fatigue is largely to blame the report
found
during Co everyone was feeling generous
said Eric Plum founder and CEO of San
Francisco based startup up tip which
aims to facilitate cashless tipping the
problem is that it reached a new
standard that we all couldn't really
live with he it particularly when it uh
comes to tipping promps at a wider range
of establishments a trend also referred
to as tip
creep now I'm reminded of uh so I saw
this pop up and there's also this kind
of viral post making the rounds on
Twitter this is some I don't know where
this is from
some restaurant owner I I sell somewhere
somewhere in New York which sounds about
right but some restaurant owner
apparently posted this message which
says uh directed at her customers which
says we expect you to tip 20% minimum
that's the end of the story period the
number is even printed right there on
the check so you don't have to do any
math when you walk in the door you enter
into a covenant if you feel any kind of
way about this other than 100% accepting
you should stay home invest in your own
sound system get some nice glasswar
install dimmers on your kitchen lights
put on some candles and make your own
cocktails I won't say that you should go
elsewhere because 20% is the minimum
expected tip in bars and restaurants all
over this city and your feelings about
the fact are irrelevant and if you're
uncomfortable with a woman having the
agency to explain any of this to you
again stay home go ahead and go buck
wild in the comments if you feel the
need uh
so this this attitude by the way is part
we hear about the tip fatigue this is
part of the reason this totally entitled
attitude and you know we've talked about
tipping uh o oh you know over over the
over the years really because it is such
an important issue and I will tell you
that this is one ISS I have been
radicalized on this I have been uh my
own position on tipping has radically
changed I mean I used to be I used to be
a big tip I used to be you know and
there's times in the past you could
probably find things that I've written
or things that I've said years ago
um uh just passionately defending the
practice of tipping and now I find
myself way on the other end of it um
where I don't want to tip anyone anymore
and and and I certainly I used to be 20%
at a
minimum um that's you know that's your
Baseline and you'd have to try really
hard to get less than
20% uh so if you like C minus service
this is how I used to operate C minus
service is 20% and if you get up into b
or A+ now I'm going 30 I might tip 35
40% very generous tip
uh now that's that's not how I look at
it anymore and 20% it's like that's
almost a maximum now your Baseline is
zero and you got to earn the tip and I
talked to a lot of people that feel the
same way about it and it's look it's not
our fault you just you pressed it way
too much in the in the in the customer
service industry everyone wants a tip
Now everywhere you
go even even places where they're not
doing
anything like you you go to a you go to
a a coffee shop and you ask for coffee
and they just pour the coffee into the
cup and handed to well I could do that
and there are plenty other you could
just do self-service and I could do that
there's nothing about your performance
of that job that I feel I need to
especially reward you're already
rewarded with your paycheck and whatever
you get paid it may not be a whole lot
but it's probably basically
what that is worth are you a few years
maybe a few decades out of school and
one wondering what the heck did I even
learn what was the point of any of that
you might even be thinking I don't have
the time to learn something new well if
that's you you're not alone and also the
good news is it's not too late Hillsdale
College is offering more than 40 free
online courses you can learn about the
works of CS Lewis or the rise and fall
of the Roman Republic the history of the
ancient Christian Church many other
subject with Hillsdale colleges online
courses if you're not sure where to
start we'll check out American
citizenship and its decline with Victor
Davis Hansen in this eight lecture
course Victor explores the history of
citizenship in the West and the threats
it faces today threats like the erosion
of the middle class The Disappearance of
our borders the growth of an
unaccountable deep State um the rise of
globalist organizations the course is
self-paced so that you can start
whenever and wherever you can start your
free course of American citizenship and
its decline with Victor Davis Hansen
today but you got to go to hillsdale.edu
Walsh to enroll there's no cost easy to
get started that's hillsdale.edu Walsh
to enroll hillsdale.edu
Walsh
so you go everywhere it's it's the it's
the the how ubiquitous tipping is how
prevalent it is everywhere and the
entitled attitude that people have about
it um and all of that has made me go all
the way to the other end and now I'm
saying you've just got it you've got to
earn it so it's fine you want to put
tipping prompts everywhere Now
everywhere you go whether you're going
to a restaurant or you're going to a
grocery store or you're going to the
dentist and now everyone wants a tip
fine I can't stop that but my my
approach to everybody including the
restaurants is that you really got to
earn it Give Me A Reason like I don't
know when I go to a the a convenience
store and buy a couple items and then
they flip the iPad around and say do you
want a
tip I always say no I'm not sure what
they could do that would make that that
would inspire me to say oh I really the
way they rang up that bottle of water I
got to award that with a tip so I'm not
sure I'm not sure what they could
do but it's
possible but you got to earn it that's
the way tipping that's the way tipping
all all we should have been and that's
the way it is it is now and if you're in
the service industry and you don't like
that uh well honestly you have your own
industry to blame if You' like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there godp
speed